et on vous le disais les bourses de
paris et francfort ont chuté de plus de
10% aujourd'hui nous sommes avec eux
olivier delamarche économistes merci
d'être avec nous olivier alors d'abord
comment interpréter justement cette
chute brutale des bourses européennes
on est dans quelque chose qu'on a jamais
connu une un pays qui est la troisième
le troisième pays de la zone euro qui
l'italie qui aujourd'hui est arrêté
c'est du jamais vu
donc on est dans quelque chose justement
où je pense qu'il faut changer de
logiciel sur sur la suite des événements
parce que c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a
pas connues qui dont on n'a aucun
historique donc c'est difficile de se
projeter et de et de prévoir quelque
chose quand vous savez que une récession
ça vaut en général une récession normale
vous 30 à 40 % sur un marché financier
sur sur un indice par rapport à la à ses
plus hauts là aujourd'hui on doit être
autour de 30% de baisse
donc ça veut dire que c'est pas fini et
c'est surtout pas fini parce que on
n'est pas dans une situation normale on
n'est pas dans une récession normale on
est dans quelque chose de beaucoup plus
profond que ça on va avoir une récession
mondiale je voyais encore des
économistes qui se posait la question de
savoir si peu dur on serait en récession
ou pas on est en récession
c'est une évidence ion inédite vous
dites qu'il faut changer de logiciel
il faut changer le logiciel c'est à dire
que on n'a pas d'eau on n'a pas
d'antécédents donc il paraît difficile
de se baser là dessus pour essayer de
savoir comment ça va se passer et on a
des gens qui n'ont pas prouvé
pour l'instant leurs compétences à
régler les problèmes donc
malheureusement
on est là gardons fataliser maquis moi
je fais allusion aux autorités
économiques et politiques actuels donc
vous avez les banques centrales qui
réagissent toujours de façon d'ailleurs
parce que l ont pas beaucoup de choix
aujourd'hui elles peuvent plus mais
c'est les taux puisque les taux sont à
zéro donc elles font ce qu'elles savent
faire le mieux c'est-à-dire faire
tourner la planche à billets et faire
tourner la planche à billets on sait
pertinemment que ça se termine mal alors
c'est ce qu'elles vont faire elles vont
parce que aujourd'hui elles n'ont pas
tellement d'options supplémentaires
elles savent très bien ça ne relancera
pas l'économie réelle mais que ça pourra
peut-être arrêter les marchés dans leur
baisse que malgré les mesures justement
aux prises annoncé en tout cas par la
banque centrale européenne pour
justement soutenir l'économie
il va malgré cela on voit aujourd'hui
que les bourses d'europe nl davis mais
tout simplement parce que les les
banques centrales
aujourd'hui ne sont pas du tout non pas
du tout la possibilité de soutenir quoi
que ce soit dans l'économie réelle
on le sait depuis 2008 depuis 2008 ils
essaient de nous expliquer que en en
créant en faisant tourner la planche à
billets en créant la mener ils vont
relancer l'économie on sait très bien
que ça n'a pas été fait que ça n'a pas
marché que ça ne sert à rien ça sert
simplement à un flat et la bulle qui
assure les actifs qui sont financiarisé
donc c'est ce qu'elle sait faire c'est
la seule chose qu'elle sache faire et
elle va elle va y aller alors pas
forcément cette fois ci sur le discours
de madame lagarde mai
ça sera ça sera fait la prochaine fois
vous avez déjà le patron de la banque du
japon qui a qui a dit que il était prêt
à acheter tout ce qu'il fallait pour
empêcher les marchés de baisser vous
avez la fête qui se mettra à faire
exactement la même chose et la bce aussi
parce que toute façon aujourd'hui dans
dans le système actuel avec les fonds de
pension avec les fonds de retraite tout
est basé sur les marchés financiers si
vous laissez les marchés financiers
s'écrouler ça veut dire que vous payez
plus les retraites aux fonctionnaires
que et ça me paraît un peu compliquée
donc aujourd'hui on a l'impression tout
de même alors en france qu'il ne se
passe rien c'est à dire que ce qu'on
peut faire quelque chose sont tétanisés
et j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont
absolument aucune intention de bouger
quoi que ce soit on est le seul pays
européens d'ailleurs à ne pas prendre de
mesures
le res prendre des mesures mais de toute
façon c'est pas le c'est pas le problème
du cornard virus le corps navires us
c'est un catalyseur et c'est un
révélateur d'une situation qui n'a
jamais été réglé depuis 2008 on a mis la
poussière sous le tapis
le coronavirus arrive la poussière
ressorts de soupapes de deux sous le
tapis et malheureusement c'est pas très
bien quoi en faire est ce qu'on peut
faire quelque chose parce que par
exemple christine lagarde elle peut
réagir est-ce qu'il ya justement pas
s'il s'agit comme elle le fait très bien
il est en fait c'est pas c'est pas elle
qui va le régler le problème
aujourd'hui on a un problème qui est de
d'économie réelle et on cherche
exactement comme 2008 à la règle et en
rajoutant de la veille on a un problème
de dette et on rajoute de la dette pour
régler ce problème de dette déjà
intellectuellement mots j'ai du mal sur
ce genre de choses et ça ne sert à rien
sauf à préparer le prochain éclatement
qui sera encore plus violent si on
empêche de
de le faire aujourd'hui qui sera encore
plus violent demain donc tout ça c'est
pas c'est pas c'est parce qu'il faut
faire aujourd'hui
malheureusement on l'a pas fait en 2008
on est en train de le payer et je dirais
maintenance et des solutions un tout
petit peu plus drastiques qu'il faudrait
prendre sauf que ils ont sont bien
incapables
merci beaucoup olivier delmarche
rappelle que vous êtes économiste merci
à vous